and I you see it's not just women that
look at other women are like oh she's up
to something bad see something little
boys do it to sex us against your own
kind it's true when I'm I'm an
embarrassment to my kind I guess yes but
I kind of faked you on though
like yeah yeah they do but major yeah
but then kind of go and start wars and
kill things so you know if I had to
choose you know why they do that though
cuz there's that woman I don't like him
sweetheart me all the wars in the world
are caused because wow I didn't know we
were that stupid
seriously man I'm thinking about it what
you do for your wife and now I was start
a war I'll be back okay alright my
totally I'm part like yes oh no no I
wanted to take over the V log oh uh no
that'll never happen Danny I'm the
master and now I get that segue Danny
you worked in a saying without me even
knowing it and you saw the title - yeah
I know
so I okay let's begin with H man this is
henchman another Marceline episode which
is a as you say a fan favorite like I
could see again I guess I see why could
she just sort of even if it's not really
evil she just sort of does her own
you know it's just like hey like I'm
gonna make something look really really
evil and honest just just singing formal
baby boy fun and so okay so she has this
henchman that's like really really old
and Finn gives up his after sliding down
that thing what the hell is the bones of
that thing that that's I want no story
behind that thing but so she goes and so
he gives up he trades himself this old
man and he becomes the henchman Finn
because the henchman and Jake keeps
trying to save him but he's too
terrified and boy some good
transformations with him in this one I
love what he sinks his head and almost
like a jar yeah cuz he's so Fred I love
always about to attack
she turns around he shakes down really
small runs away I mean good good jokes
with that um and Phil agrees but he's
constantly he keeps thinking something
bad is gonna happen she makes it okay
some bad guy that's always something
nice and positive and you know actually
helpful most of the time and by the end
he says hey I've caught on to your game
and she's like oh that's no fun and they
split ways pretty much she fires him for
being the henchmen as the psalmist but
not as much fun if she can't mess with
him
oh and then Jake tries to kill her for
the first time we see what happens when
she said sunlight gets I was a gruesome
budget this are like Yanks yeah the code
just had her go hello but no she's like
I'll get over ed and crumbling and stuff
so that was cool and yeah that's the fun
episode I mean I do like the character I
like I like that she's keeping a Maz
toes I like that you can't quite fully
figure her out like like I said she just
seems like a party girl like just saying
anything she wants to do she just sort
of does I think that's always a fun
character I mean if she wants to even
for like title as queen of vampires like
if she just wanted to do something good
for phyllite help somebody no reason you
know just yeah I like it's just just
whatever she's in the mood for I just
think that's a fun cool character so how
about you guys
well I loved her and I loved loved loved
this episode I loved I think what I love
about her is it might mean everything
that you said - she has that certain
freedom of she's free in a sense and
that she'll do whatever she wants and it
doesn't matter and I think a lot well
okay I'm giving her backstory that
probably is completely wrong but I don't
care probably is oh I'm sure I've just
decided in my head
but this is what's gonna happen no I
just I felt like the way she was acting
in this episode it's it was pretty
interesting because it's like someone
that kind of just never really fit in or
someone that's kind of been you know
just viewed differently and it's like
instead of sitting back and going all
man this sucks everybody's afraid of me
because I'm a vampire but I'm a really
great girl you know it's just like yeah
okay I'm a little weird I'm a little odd
but whatever I'll do what I want I know
I'm not a bad person it's fine and and
it's kind of like I feel like a lot of
times you you develop some friendships
with certain people where you have
certain you know ideas about a person
when you first meet them and the more
you get to know them you're like oh my
gosh they're kind of great or they're
kind of this or they're kind of that and
it was really weird it's like she owns
that she's not normal she's a vampire
queen and people are scared of her and
she owns it and that's okay cuz she
knows that she's not really doing
anything wrong and she doesn't have to
cuz she doesn't want to she's sometimes
she does rawlings there she did keep why
not I guess she didn't technically all
the places Finn was going in the last
episode she did technically doing
anything wrong when if you think about
it what was it it was like well she just
thought they were really great and she
just wanted what they had cuz it was
great I mean it's kind of an immature
way of dealing with it but in a sense
again she wasn't malicious about it she
wasn't kicking them out because she was
just a jerk she she just wanted what
they had left man not because it was
being a jerk but was a perk sure that
was fun yes but everything I know is too
is that I never knows the last epicentre
knows the bite marks thank ya yeah I
actually never ever picked up on that so
you know sideshows okay so she was
definitely like not bored but bitten so
she probably had whatever a different
life you know before this and then
however she rose to the ranks of vampire
queen if that maybe she's just the last
one she declares herself the queen of
is there something I'm saying we don't
know her backstory so she if she won't
be a fun one to know the backstory of
God I wouldn't mind knowing like how she
got not necessarily like how she became
a vampire everything but just how she
got this person out because it is such a
fun I've seen everything personality
like I've seen the world nothing shocks
me more how I'll just have fun you know
kind of thing so it's did I go more into
the back five episodes you will learn
it's the Episode one of season two you
learn a tiny tiny bit about not
necessarily her backstory but her family
if you will but yes she is one of the
characters where you learn a lot about
her backstory that's cool they expand a
lot on it and it's very interesting cool
very cool
so how about you what do you got I just
thought this episode is about how the
way women play mind games boyfriends you
know the husband you know she said a
sexist thing last time but she just
barely got away with it because she is
that saying now you're gonna throw in
there no but look at the look at how the
episode goes and Finn said it himself
she just likes to play games and women
like to play games with guys and women
you know ha at ha now to be fair men
definitely like their games do you know
what okay I know what you're talking
about
no no but the things have branched out
more there's a lot of things where I
used to really think like oh yeah well
women do this men do that and stuff but
I think especially now things are
branching out much more where I see
women doing stuff from my lot usually a
guy thinking men do stuff where it's
like oh that's usually a woman think
both positive and negative and I think
it really is branching out more and more
and I think some things do lean more
towards women more towards men but I
don't know I think stuff like that is
really branching out because I've seen
some guys do some dick mind games with
women I know I was just talking the
episode snow but with this episode it
seemed to be kind of like if thin and
Marceline were dating in this episode
we'll say it's kind of like the mind
games that the girl would be playing on
him or you know with him and all that
stuff that's kind of how I looked
a citrus and of course you have Jake as
Finn's best friend who hates who phineas
quote unquote dating and they're not
having a number mate but it's kind of
like that you know no she's brainwashed
you think about it it's all that and
that's like a lot of times what happens
when guys date someone their friends
comment is they oh no you just took it
it's like okay we have some fun comments
no that's just the way I saw it
personally no I love Marceline
Marceline's a great character and I
think Jory's right though like she is
that type of character with just like I
want to be accepted but I don't know
exactly how to get into your circle of
friends or to hang out with you proper
so I have to do it my own way
she's probably in denial about whether
or not she kind of wants to be a mess
circle friends or now I think her
thought is surly well I'm doing this cuz
it'll just kind of be fun and some
friends of it yeah cool but it doesn't
really matter to me what in all
probability it does really matter if she
just doesn't really know it so ya know
I'm curious to know more about this
character i'm glad they are gonna go oh
they go more into her backstory
um but yeah so i I liked it I thought
was a good episode any other totally
horrible sexist remarks either you do
that no but I love her voice the the
voice actress who does the singing is
wonderful it's the same that's what I
mean the voice actress of Marceline also
has a very good singing voice I do enjoy
I really do enjoy her voice I also do
like how the the nice lullaby song is
about why you know ripping eyes like
that I go one one other thing a before I
let Jason face out fear uh no is it more
and more the again I think when we
started off I'm like you know could they
say sexy on a kid show it's like watches
last you episodes like we got bra thrown
in there I think Jake said that's
totally balls in like the last episode
like do
my practice button this one yeah I mean
it's like they're I don't think I'm
upset just more shocked I just shocked
that they really can't get away with so
much I mean I guess it's always well can
you make the argument that balls could
be like balls the kids you know play
with like a baseball or something like
that it's like you could technically you
know well maybe that's that's the thing
is that it's so random and so confusing
remember when you first started watching
and you're like I just don't know what I
watched him that's how it gets through
the censors they're maybe they just see
it it's like you know what don't say
like any of the five swear words you
know can't make it on TV and we're good
confuse the censors it does seem that
way it does see how they'll just watch
and just be like okay just while we
watching it effect your time oh just
just give it a pass did I say any swear
words not okay just give it a pass so
yeah but you Jason
no just random sexist government I'm
gonna go play in the in there in the
knife ring segue all right